we all know the founders of the biggest
companies and services in the world
apple is steve jobs and steve wozniak
microsoft is bill gates and paul allen
google is larry page and sergey brin and
so on and so forth we also know that
electricity was discovered by benjamin
franklin and the telephone was invented
by alexander graham bell and the light
bulb was invented by thomas edison and
nikola tesla yet virtually none of us
know the inventors of the network that
we spend the vast majority of our time
on the internet the internet was created
by two computer scientists named vinton
surf and bobcon and the network was
launched on january 1st 1983. since then
the internet has become an integral part
of our lives yet this duo does not
dominate the billionaires list or forbes
magazines and interviews most people
wouldn't even recognize them on the
street which is quite ironic given how
influential they are so here's how vinta
serve and bob khan created the internet
and what they're up to today
taking a look back vinceriff was born on
june 23 1943 in new haven connecticut
his father worked at an aeronautics
company which gave vint an interest in
engineering from very early on in fact
when he was in high school he would get
a job at rocketdyne where he got an
opportunity to work on the apollo
program he wrote statistical analysis
software that helped test the f1 engines
that were used by the famous saturn v so
by the time vince graduated high school
he was already more accomplished than
most of us ever will be but he was just
getting started vince would go on to
attend stanford university where he
majored in mathematics he would complete
this degree in 1965 and go on to join
ibm as a systems engineer he didn't
stick around here for long doa as his
true passion was research so he would
return to school to further his
education this time at vint went to ucla
where he pursued a master's in computer
science this experience was especially
important because this is where he would
meet the other inventor of the internet
bob khan anyway vint would finish his
masters in 1970 and he would pursue a
phd in computer science also from ucla
it doesn't look like vint really wanted
to leave academia because he would just
become an assistant professor at
stanford after graduating in 1972. for
the next four years he would spend the
vast majority of his time on researching
pack and network interconnection
protocols and creating the tcp ip
protocol suite he would eventually leave
academia in 1976 at age 33 but his new
job wasn't all that different he would
join darpa where he continued the same
research for the next six years but
unlike academia vint had the opportunity
to implement his research into real
projects at darpa for example the
department of defense would use the
fourth version of tcp slash ip for all
military computer networking purposes
vint ended up working for darpa up until
1982 at which point he switched over to
mca digital information services and
this is when the internet would
officially go live
moving on to bob khan's backstory bob
was born on december 23 1938 in new york
like many of the people that we cover on
this channel bob was quite curious and
intelligent from a very young age
despite this bob was never able to fully
explore his interests throughout his
childhood due to his family situation
you see his mom was suffering from an
undisclosed heart condition which meant
that bob had to spend much of his free
time caring for his mother in fact this
was one of the main reasons that he
would attend local colleges for his
bachelor's first he attended queen's
college for two years before he
transferred over to city college of new
york where he earned his bachelor's in
electrical engineering by the time he
finished his bachelor's bob says that it
was clear to him that he was not a big
fan of lab work but he did find math
quite intriguing ironically though in
january of 1960 bob would get a job at
bell labs which literally has lab in the
name he didn't stick around for long
though he was applying to masters
programs and would be accepted into
princeton princeton was a big jump up
from city college but bob was up for the
challenge in fact he thrived under the
pressure and would even end up running
the graduate school seminar series bob
would end up getting his master's in
electrical engineering in 1962 and he
would instantly turn around and pursue a
phd in electrical engineering after
completing his phd in 1964 like event
bob would become an assistant professor
but he would teach at mit instead of
stanford bob wasn't a big fan of being a
professor though he felt that the job
was a little stultifying which meant
that it stifled enthusiasm initiative
and freedom of action so he only did
this for two years before he switched
over to an engineering consulting firm
called bbn where he served as senior
scientist at the time bb and then was
working on a new computer network called
arpanet which was being funded by darpa
bob didn't know it at the time but this
is what would eventually lead to the
creation of the internet
the characteristic that made arpanet
unique was that it relied on packet
switching this is when a large piece of
data is split up into smaller chunks
called packets which are then sent over
the network these packets are then
combined to create the original piece of
data at the destination the researchers
found that this was far more efficient
and reliable and the packet switching
has since become a standard for
transferring data over networks bob's
role in this project was to link up host
computers from institutions to this
network and as you might have guessed
one of the institutions that are
involved in this project was ucla bob
would travel to ucla in september of
1969 to set up arpanet nodes at the
university which led him to meeting vint
cerf anyway a few years later in 1972
bob would help organize the world's
first international conference on
computer communication which is when
arpanet would be revealed to the public
after the public reveal bob would leave
bbn and join darpa full time there he
was tasked with linking together
military radio networks from around the
world in other words he had to create a
network of networks hence the name
internet bob would recruit help from
stanford professor event surf and
together they would work on creating
this network of networks this was
actually extremely challenging because
the duo had to connect more networks
than they ever imagined when bob was
given the job he thought that he had to
figure out how to connect five to ten
big networks but he actually had to
connect hundreds of thousands which
eventually turned into millions using
arpanet didn't seem peaceable for such a
large task especially if they wanted it
to last a long time so the duo started
working on their own protocol called tcp
ip tcp stands for transmission control
protocol and it's responsible for
splitting up data at the source and
reassembling the packets of data at the
destination meanwhile ip stands for
internet protocol and it's responsible
for ensuring that the packets of data
are actually sent to the right
destination over the next several years
bob and vince would perfect data
transfers using packet switching and
they would eventually launch tcp slash
ip guidelines in 1980. tcp slash ip
wasn't the only protocol that could link
up these networks
some other famous protocols include ftp
or file transfer protocol and ncp or
network control protocol but in the end
it was tcp ip that would become the
standard for arpanet the switch to tcp
ip took place on january 1 1983 and this
was marked as the day the internet was
born
while the internet was officially live
there was still a long way to go in
making this technology accessible to the
public and that's exactly what this duo
would start working on next by the time
arpanet adopted the tcp slash ip
protocol vint had already left darfa and
he was working at mci digital there then
would begin working on the world's first
commercial email service that could work
through the internet meanwhile bob would
stick around at darpa a little longer
but he too would leave in 1985 to find a
corporation for national research
initiatives this was a non-profit group
that was dedicated to making the
internet accessible to the public they
accomplished this by sourcing funding
for projects that made internet user
friendly through tools like browsers
vint would soon join the organization as
vice president in 1986 and he would help
with the fundraising effort the reagan
administration was rather supportive of
this initiative but the real money ended
up coming from the private sector as
opposed to the government by 1990 the
private sector had donated 500 million
dollars and these fonts would eventually
be used to launch the world's first
internet browser and atm in 1990 with
the help of atnt and loads of other
programmers and the rest is history
moving on in 1992 bob and vinto will
create the internet society which was
yet another non-profit dedicated to
promoting development and adoption of
the internet despite founding something
that was so influential neither bob nor
vince really made that much money from
finding the internet itself you see it
no one really runs the internet it's
more of a decentralized network of
networks that's run by thousands of
companies at universities and
governments from around the world
so there was really no way to monetize
internet itself which is quite ironic
given that dozens of multi-hundred
billion dollar companies were built off
the internet at one point in 1988 vin
did try to privatize the internet but
the internet was already too
decentralized by this point so his
efforts weren't that successful
fortunately though vint would end up
joining google in 2005 as a vice
president and this made him quite
wealthy today he's worth roughly 45
million dollars bob however would just
stick around as non-profits and he still
works there to this day there's no
verifiable net worth for bob but some
sources put it at around 8 million
obviously neither of these guys are
struggling for money but given that
people like jeff bezos mark zuckerberg
larry page and sergey brinner are all
worth 100 billion each this is nothing
while vint nor bob never got the
financial benefits that they deserved
they did get plenty of awards these guys
have won so many awards that if we went
through all of them it would likely take
an hour so we'll just stick to the two
most notable awards
in december of 1997 bob and vince were
awarded the national medal of technology
from president bill clinton and several
years later in 2005 both vint and bob
would be awarded a presidential medal of
freedom from president bush i think we
can all agree that these two more than
deserve these medals anyway today vin
serves in a bunch of advisory roles all
over the place for example he serves as
a commissioner for the broadband
commission for digital development
similarly he serves on the board of
advisors of scientists and engineers for
america vind also regularly gives
interviews and speeches regarding
thoughts about the future of the
internet there's plenty of these on
youtube if you're interested meanwhile
bob has chosen to lead a much more
subtle life he doesn't serve on a bunch
of boards and do interviews all the time
but he does still work at his
non-profits and is still committed to
making the internet as accessible as
possible and that's what happened to the
founders of the internet did you know
about vint and bob before this video
comment that down below
also drop a like if you think vint and
bob deserve more recognition and of
course consider checking out our discord
community to suggest future video ideas
and consider subscribing and see more
questions logically answered but until
then i'm hari and i'll see you guys on
the next one
you